thaler et de calais olivier vous voulez
savoir quand ils reviennent ils sont là
car il est alors ça fait une paye qu'on
s'est pas vu
alors ça fait une paye qu'on s'est pas
vue mais ses membres à vos câlins de
serge lama bravo à la salicaire pense
que mickaël soirée face sûr de conserver
son titre de champion du monde de blind
test bien alors on va on vous retrouve
pas de cette année comme l'année
dernière tous les jours sur comédie le
19 à 20 heures et de 18 à 19 heures fête
l'autoroute de la fortune brands 2 way
et en attendant les très heureuse
bravo les compagnons et non à la michael
intervient se tenir à québec et iris et
qui michael mais michael c'est le mec à
gagner chaque semaine depuis le début de
la saison trois semaines de suite et il
est en train de devenir vraiment star le
mec break rambouillet ce soir et ce soir
il a un petit peu peur
il a un petit côté qu'elle aimait ll ya
que linda hardy quand même a jamais eu
de réponse vous la part de la moindre
frappe